understanding South Africa's genocide
case against Israel part one some
context on December 29th 2023 South
Africa filed an application to begin
Court proceedings against Israel they
argu that Israel is committing genocide
against the Palestinian people in the
Gaza Strip I'm going to go into detail
on this document in part three but these
allegations include killing Palestinians
causing them harm and trying to destroy
the Palestinians as a group South Africa
submitted this to the international
court of justice which was set up in
1945 to settle disputes between nations
the final ruling will probably take
years to actually come out but the icj
has come out and ruled on a provisional
measure ordering Israel to quote take
all measures within its power to prevent
genocide and crucially to ensure the
preservation of evidence so they can
properly investigate this but they did
not order Israel to stop military
operations as South Africa had requested
in part two I will explain what genocide
actually is per International legal
definitions so we can learn what that
definition teaches us about this case